all right in his explosive new book
called catch and kill Ronan Farrow
details allegations of sexual assault in
the media industry and his former bosses
alleged attempts to stifle his reporting
the book describes sexual assault
allegations against disgraced Hollywood
mogul Harvey Weinstein and former NBC
News anchor Matt Lauer both men have
denied any wrongdoing in a moment we'll
talk with Farrell about his book his
Pulitzer prize-winning reporting helped
launch the me2 movement which inspired
women to come forward the movement also
revealed allegations against many
powerful men including Charlie Rose and
les Moonves here at CBS in catch and
kill Ronan Farrow says he had reporting
in August 2017 about Harvey Weinstein's
alleged sexual misconduct including
anonymous corroborating witnesses a
silhouetted accuser on camera and even
secretly recorded audio with Weinstein
accuser Umbra Gutierrez but ferro claims
NBC said it wasn't enough he says NBC
News president Noah Oppenheim eventually
suggested Pharaoh take the story
elsewhere writing quote any further
reporting you're doing is not on behalf
of or with the blessing of NBC Pharaoh
published his investigation nearly two
months later in The New Yorker catch and
kill also names one of Matt Lauer's
accusers for the first time former NBC
employee Brooke nevels says Lauer raped
her in his hotel room
at the 2014 Sochi Olympics that
accusation led to Lauer's dismissal from
NBC for sexual misconduct in November
2017 Lauer staunchly denies an assault
took place saying the encounter was
consensual
last night Lauer's attorney fought back
rioting pharaoh continues his attempt to
monetize the me2 movement using
salacious allegations as promotional
trinkets to sell his book and nbc's noah
Oppenheim also released a new rebuttal
writing Matt Lauer's actions were
abhorrent Ronin Pharaohs book takes that
undeniable fact
and twists it into a lie alleging we
were a company with a lot of secrets we
have no secrets and nothing to hide
NBC also calls pharaoh's claim about
their quashing the Weinstein story a
conspiracy theory and Ronan Farrow joins
us now welcome Ronan good to be here in
this statement from NBC which I should
say is is six pages long very detailed
yeah NBC News president Noah not Noah
Oppenheim says your book is quote built
on a series of distortions confused
timelines and outright outright
inaccuracies look this book is an
extraordinarily meticulously
fact-checked work of investigative
journalism to years of reporting one of
the senior fact checkers at The New
Yorker checked it I'll let the reporting
in the book stand on its own we're very
confident in it and it's been amazing to
see how the press has rallied around it
I think people have seen it for what it
is what have you heard from people
inside NBC there has been an outpouring
of support from journalists at this
company and sources coming forward
saying they too have stories that's very
common all of this is honestly very
common with these kinds of investigative
stories when I reported those stories
about CBS that you just mentioned
similar campaign to undercut the
reporting that revved up and similar
support that ultimately carried the day
well there was always two sides to every
story I'm really curious because Matt
Lauer came out really with guns blazing
responding to you made it very clear
from his point of view that it was
certainly consensual and she was very
willing this really is a he-said
she-said story thrown at the end of the
day the allegations about Matt Lauer how
do you decide who is telling the truth
here so I think one of the
transformations of recent years is that
we've come to understand that actually I
come at this from a legal background you
can corroborate claims of sexual
violence and brooke nevels his claim has
been found credible even by NBC News
which took the step of firing Matt Lauer
and same by me and by the fact checkers
working on this she describes a an
evening that matches up with the
timeline given by others there there
were eyewitnesses to what happened
before and after that moment she
described this event consistently over
the years and look it's telling that NBC
News paid her a seven-figure settlement
to
ensure that she can't talk about what
the network knew about that well I want
to want to stop you about your
fact-checking process because Matt
Lauer's lawyer says many allegations
that are being circulated were never
raised during any fat check
fact-checking process and despite Rita
repeated requests for an advanced copy
of the book have not been provided to me
did you have a conversation did you talk
to Matt at any time look that very often
without talking about Matt Lauer
specifically as you know in our
profession people will fact check or
have conversations and give you the
responses in an off-the-record capacity
or under some other ground rule that
prevents me from answering a question
directly like that however I will say
that every single individual where
there's a serious allegation against
them described in this book had an ample
fair window to fact-check them with
respect to Matt Lauer specifically when
you read the book it's very clear this
section is fair and even generous to him
and his thinking is reflected in detail
so there was nothing surprising in that
letter except obviously as many
survivors have commented on the tone
which was very angry and had some menace
in it was surprising to some people one
of the major discrepancies between what
NBC is saying and what you're reporting
is the question of agreements prior to
Matt Lauer's firing apparently involving
women apparently of involving this
behavior NBC says this morning that
those were completely routine not
related to sexual harassment or assault
what makes you say otherwise
tawny they had a euphemism at this
company called enhanced severance and we
talked to multiple people involved in
each of that those transactions
including senior executives on the NBC
side who were involved in them who said
these were explicitly arrangements to
shutup women with allegations of
misconduct within this company and
that's something we saw at CBS vision
and other media companies and it's a
practice that correctly is being called
into question by journalists they say in
the statement enhanced severance was
routine and was paid out to to hundreds
if not thousands of people and what we
document in this book is that these
settlements were an elevated amount that
was atypical and but we fully include in
the book their claim that it is
coincidental that these women had
complaints about Matt Lauer and about
others including executives there the
people involved say something else
the bulk of the book though is about
your efforts to tell the Harvey
Weinstein story and working with it's
very ironic that the black cube people
that were following you allegedly at
Harvey's request end up
reaching out to you because they wanted
to talk to you about how they felt about
the job they were doing but the bulk of
the book is about your efforts to tell
the Harvey Weinstein's story and in the
end NBC killed the story because they
said you did not have enough facts that
didn't reach their level of journalism
how do we know that this is not just an
they're saying it's an axe to grind on
your part so the book is as I said fair
and even generous them in every turn
there was a very extensive fact-checking
process to make sure every one of their
rebuttals is in there because the Harvey
story didn't run on NBC ultimately took
it to ultimately took it to the New
Yorker and wasn't obviously the producer
who worked on that story at a working
level put out a piece in the last few
days corroborating that saying we were
ordered to stop and that is the point
Gail
there are untruths being put out by NBC
there's lies in that statement that
wouldn't fact check they admitted to us
they never fact checked any of these
memos that you referred to
rebutting this they are concealing the
fact that they actively ordered us to
stop yes we had multiple named women and
every draft of this story we had audio
of Harvey Weinstein admitting to a crime
but more pertinently they ordered us to
stop this book answers why
well they ordered you to stop but it
hasn't stopped yet the conversation
continues it's ongoing it's an important
one including at this company and I
appreciate how transparent you guys have
all been and confronting that after my
reporting book CBS there's been a lot of
change and I know journalists here are
happy about that and Journal we never
thought we'd be part of that story so
absolutely you did great coverage of it
about it and you know on the NBC side
there are fantastic journalists at that
company exactly a tribute to them many
of them are sources in this story and
they are anguished over what's happening
right now and some of the lies that are
being put out by their own corporate
leadership and some of the executive
interference and coverage it's a good
conversation that's happening
Ronen thank you very much his book catch
and kill lies spies and a conspiracy to
protect predators goes on sale tomorrow